here's a money-saving tolls tip for
Valentine's Day that we did in 2012 take
a glass of apple juice add some
alka-seltzer boom champagne
here's a quick here's a clip from the
French television show
it's called lay to toast a Mukhtar
translation mocked arse tips well
Duchamp and Papa share not edition
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
boo is right yes they stole the whole
idea plus even the graphics and the way
it's presented unbelievable but guess
what this story is getting stranger it
gets worse our research department just
uncovered another country ripping off
tools tips this time it's a show in
Germany again I am not making this up as
absolutely real they have two guys in a
prop room instead of one guy other than
that it's still exactly the same bit the
postal brothers x-men edition Han Kanata
envy him from Sac City last Christmas
okay and yours yes boo those Germans
yeah
though here's love grenade yeah see bill
this is the only difference bill says
boom at the end boom right whatever
champagne the French guy says BIM and
the German guy says Zack fight each
that's it that's the only difference
it's incredible wait what's that okay
now I'm getting word that if it's spread
to Italy
take a look you got me no they're just
one sample a keyboard a la fille cheetah
a boo
[Applause]
okay okay that one we made out all right
we just wanted the Pope to say ah boom
boom boom
the other two are absolutely real okay
and that got us wondering all right
what's gonna happen if we don't stop
this ripoff of our tolls tips right this
very minute we've already seen bill
tolls tips spread from France to Germany
and we all know what happens when the
Germans get a hold of an idea they like
god save us all our show
it took us it costs us six hundred
thousand dollars for that animation yeah
our show we didn't have the money we
took it from an orphanage anyway but it
was worth it anyway our show created
this bit it's taking over the world and
we're not gonna see one lousy you're
owning this thing they're just ripping
us off it all started with that stupid
French show well I'm sorry to spa I'm on
post but this one's on you if you don't
clean up this mess if you don't stop the
spread of tells tips I'll have no choice
but to send bill tell himself to France
in fact I understand bill is already
getting ready pack your suitcase throw
away the deodorant boom ready for France
[Applause]
you